The attachment theory argues
that a strong emotional and physical bond
to one primary caregiver in our first years of life,
is critical to our development.
If our bonding is strong and we are securely attached,
then we feel safe to explore the world.
We know there is always that safe base,
to which we can return to anytime.
If our bond is weak, we feel insecurely attached.
We are afraid to leave or explore a rather
scary-looking world.
Because we are not sure if we can return.
People who are securely attached
are said to have greater trust,
can connect to others
and as a result are more successful in life.
Insecurely attached people tend to mistrust others,
lack social skills and have problems
forming relationships.
There is one type of secure attachment
and there are 3 types of insecure attachments:
Anxious/Ambivalent
Anxious/Avoidant
and Anxious/Disorganized.
In responses to distress,
the first 3 react organized,
while the last acts disorganized.
To understand the theory better,
let's look at
Mr and Ms Smith, who have 4 children.
Luka, Ann, Joe and Amy.
The Smiths are lovely parents,
who cuddle, make frequent eye contact,
speak warmly,
and are always there for their kids.
But one day Mr Smith falls very sick and dies.
For Mrs Smith life now becomes very difficult.
She spend all day working,
while at the same time trying to care for her children.
And impossible task.
At 6 years of age, Luka’s brain is for the most part developed,
his character strong and his world view shaped.
The new situation does not affect him much -
he knows there still is always mom -
his safe-haven.
He feels securely attached.
Later he turns into a trusting and optimistic
young man.
His self image is positive.
Ann, who is 3, has problems coping with the
new lack of attention.
To Ann, her mother now acts unpredictably.
She is anxious about their relationship,
and as a result becomes clingy.
To get her mom’s attention,
she has to raise her emotional state and scream.
When her mom finally reacts with a predictable response,
she herself acts ambivalent
and doesn't show her true feelings.
Later in life, others think Ann is unpredictable
or moody.
Her self image is less positive.
Her attachment style Anxious Ambivalent.
2-year old Joe, spends his days with his uncle,
who loves him,
but thinks that a good education means being strict.
If little Joe shows too much emotions or is too loud,
his Uncle gets angry and sometimes punitive.
This scares Joe.
He learns that to avoid fear,
he has to avoid showing his feelings -
also in other situations.
As an adult he continues this strategy
and has problems to enter relationships.
His image of himself is rather negative.
His attachment is: Anxious Avoidant
Amy, who is just one year old,
gets sent to a nursery.
The staff there is poorly trained,
overworked and often very stressed.
Some are outright abusive.
Amy therefore becomes anxious
of the very people she seeks security from -
a conflict which totally disorganizes
her ideas about love and safety.
As she is experiencing fear without resolution,
she tries to avoid all social situations.
As an adult she thinks of herself as unworthy of love.
Her self image is very negative.
He attachment is anxious disorganized
Our attachment is formed in the very first
years of our lives,
a time when we are too young to communicate
our anxiety
and as a result can experience high levels of stress.
Then our adrenal gland -
an organ sitting on top of our kidneys -
produces the stress-hormones
adrenaline and cortisol.
The heart rate increases,
the blood pressure goes up
and we become alert.
If that happens frequently, it is called toxic stress.
Toxic, because it impairs the development
of a child's brain,
and weakens the immune system.
In embryos or at a very young age,
toxic stress can even switch the expressions of genes,
which can affect our health many decades later.
By simulating a Strange Situation,
we can assess an attachment style,
already by the age of one.
To do this, we let the child play with their
mothers for a few minutes inside a room.
Then the child is left alone.
The key moment is the child's reaction when
her mother returns.
Securely attached children first usually hug
their mother,
then can calm down and eventually get back to playing.
Insecurely attached children can be
ambivalent and avoidant.
Some can't stop crying or refuse to continue playing.
The long term effects of our attachment in the early years, are well documented.
Using the theory, researchers at Minnesota University
were able to predict already at age 3,
if a child would dropout of high school with 77% accuracy.
In another study, undergraduates at Harvard
were asked to assess how close they felt to their parents.
35 years later they were ask about their health.
91% of those who said they had a rather broken
relationship with their mother,
were also diagnosed with health issues,
including coronary artery disease,
hypertension, and alcoholism.
For those that had reported a warm relationship,
the figure of poor health diagnosis was just 45%.
But there is another reason
why the early years deserve special attention.
They are the starting place for subsequent
behaviors.
A kid that feels securely attached at age 2,
can make friends at kindergarten.
Their worldview gets reinforced with every interaction
and they develop optimism.
As a result they make good relationships at school,
then at colleague and later at work.
Highly insecurely attached children
can miss out on this opportunity.
Psychologist John Bowlby, a pioneer in attachment theory, allegedly said,
“What cannot be communicated to the mother,
cannot be communicated to the self.”
In other words: those who feel insecurely attached,
might not quite understand themselves.
To get to know who they are and what they feel,
they might have to go way back in time.